thank you
hello everyone I'm Dana Shamir I'm going
to talk about an interactive Universal
argument
and this is a joint welcome in
meritanski Omar panette and Thomas
so I will start with the most basic
notion in this talk that we already saw
today a lot which is the same arguments
so
it's the same argument is simply a proof
system for some language in NP
and we have the standard properties of
completeness and computational soundness
where in computational soundness I mean
soundness holds against the polynomial
adversary
and the reason it is succinct is because
of the efficiency which is also called
double efficiency so the proverb grams
in time polynomial in the input which
means it's enough for the prover to
determine the language and the verify
runs in time linear in the input so it
needs the help of the approver in order
to decide the language
okay so this is a succinct argument and
it it is a central score it is a central
Concept in cryptography uh many
different Notions are being studied and
in this talk I'm going to focus on one
influential notion which is a universal
argument
so um in Universal arguments were
introduced by black and gold eye and in
one sentence the idea is that if we use
succinct arguments for any language in
NP we can bring we can construct a
protocol to prove this language
but what if we want one proof system to
prove all languages in NP at once
together in the same protocol so
to say what it means more formally
firstly we need to define the language
that our argument is going to prove and
this is the universal language so
intuitively it contains all
non-deterministic computations and what
I mean by that is that it contains all
non-domestic Turing machines inputs to
return machines X and some time t such
that M accepts X within these steps
okay so um this is the universal
language and now
um note that any uh computation in NP uh
this language covers okay I can write
any competition in NP in this in this
way using a non-terministic hearing
machine but there are also some more
computations in this language uh as you
can see T can be anything it can also be
super polynomial okay so this language
isn't in NP
yes so this language is a nnp and so we
can't use the synth argument as is to
prove this language
and so these are Universal argument so
simply is simply an argument to prove
the universal language
so it is the same drawing that we had
before only now uh the instance that we
work on is an instance to the universal
language of the form MXT
yes so
um
uh so T here doesn't have to be
polynomial okay okay we can't I can't
give you in advance some polynomial
bound on all of the T in this language
and if I want to decide what what you
can suggest is okay let's uh suggest the
the compilation the Trans Am
non-deterministically on X 40 steps
but I don't have a polynomial bound on T
So this computation isn't necessarily
polynomial
to use like a unary representation of T
like one to the T then that would be
nice what did you suggest yeah like why
can't you use like once like unary
instead for like a binary stream you put
like a unit representation it's like one
to the T
then it's an empty language and
but then um the approver is always going
to run in polynomial time so what does
that imply on like the values of T which
we can actually so actually what I was
about to say is uh we allowed the
program to run in time polynomial in the
computation time okay so the program can
decide the language okay okay uh so yeah
so the universal argument is an argument
for the universal language and when I
talk about double efficiency now I say
that the program runs in polynomial time
in t Okay so the government can decide
the language and the verifier
but it runs in time a poly logarithmic
index so it's the same it can Define the
decide the language on its own
and we have the exact same properties of
completeness and computational soundness
and now I know that the computational
soundness holds against polynomial
adversaries where the Lambda here is the
security parameter we can think of it as
it is the size of the in of the input X
and so
uh yeah so sound assault against
polynomial adversaries and they just
want to emphasize here that um the
adversary of polynomial size it can
claim any statement it can even claim
statement uh with t that is super
polynomial okay so we have an adversary
that our advisory might try to make
statements that it can't even compute
okay so this is an interesting uh
something interesting here and you will
see it later when we try to construct
Universal argument
and so we take it or we take T to be
less than 2 to the power of Lambda
so this is a universal argument and and
as I said this is going to be our
Central uh Topic in this talk so why is
it important and to explain why it's
important let me just emphasize the
differences between the succinct
argument and in a universal argument so
if I use a succinct argument for any
polynomial upper bound on T that you
give me so so for some fixed polynomial
I can give you a proof system for this
type of computations okay
but if I use a universal argument here I
can give you a proof system for anything
at once okay so that's the main
difference
and let me give you two examples where
it is useful so
the first example is the barracks zero
knowledge phone on Black Box simulation
and this is actually this was actually
the original motivation for office work
on universal arguments so
in short uh the in this protocol the
prover tries to prove to the verify to
the verifiers I'm playing that depends
on the verifiers code okay and when I
construct the protocol I don't know in
advance what is going to be the size of
the cheating verifier and that's the
reason I need here Universal album
another important example which was just
mentioned before is the incremental
verifiable computation and what I want
to compute a very long computation and I
want to be able to prove it a
one step at a time while the computation
is taking place
and so as you can see while I'm starting
to prove the computation I don't know in
advance I don't know what T is going to
be and it's I already started running
the protocol and I don't know what is
going to be I don't have any idea if it
there is some bound on it
so this is also an important example
okay so
um
we talked about Universal arguments
let's see what we know about them now
so
um
first about the same argument and what
we know first about synthetic so there
is the classic result of Killian that
construct a for any language in NP gives
a succinct assistant argument uh
assuming Collision resistant hash
and okay so uh we have this result and
we can start asking now if it's
Universal what about universality in
this result
um so if we look carefully we see that
it is universal but in some week sense
Okay so
I can use this protocol to prove any
computation but
I need to know in advance some upper
bound on T T Bar and
and then I also need the Collision
resistant hash to be secure against
adversaries of size polynomial in Tiba
okay and so why why did it did I say
it's a little weak
um so as I said before the universal
language also contains a super
polynomial computations
so if I try to find some matching Tea
Bar here I get that my Collision
resistant hash has to be secure at least
against super polynomial adversaries or
even more and the questions we ask when
we talk about the universal argument is
is this inherent do we really have to
assume super polynomial assumption
assumption and it seems like maybe it
isn't maybe we can skip it because as I
said we only want our argument to be
secure against polynomial adversaries
and so actually yes that that this was
the state of the first one Barack and
Goldberg started walking on universal
elements and
and
yes they showed that
um you you don't need to a super
polynomial assumption so we can
construct Universal argument for entity
and our assumption only needs to be
secure against polynomial adversaries
which is just the standard Collision
resistant hash the same that we had
after a succinct argument
okay
um right so we have a universal argument
and but what I didn't tell you till now
is that both these protocols become full
messages
and as we already discussed today there
are many walks on trying to get rid of
um interactivity in many settings and
this is our question today too whether
we can make the universal argument
non-interactive
and if you think about it in the example
that I gave before about incrementary
verifiable computation and it is very
important that the proof will be inter
non-interactive
okay so this is our question today are
there non-interactive Universal
arguments
okay so let me go back to the beginning
and just say what is a non-interactive
argument
and again it's just it's a very similar
to the same argument and it is
entanglement only now the approver just
sends one message to the verifier
and the fair file according to this one
message decides whether to accept all to
widgets
and as we saw today in the system and
interactive setting we need to add a
common reference string that both proven
and verify unknown
now we have the same properties of
completeness and computational soundness
and efficiency okay and so this is our
non-interactive argument and note that
the setting that I show here is a
publicly verifiable setting now also
um works on in the setting of a
privately verifiable setting and and
today I'm going to focus on the publicly
verifiable but our results work for both
okay so yeah this is an uninteractive
argument and as we saw before
in the interactive arguments we can
Define universal non-interactive
arguments that just choose the universal
language
okay so now uh I want to tell you what
we know about non-interactive
and so there are tons of Works about
um
um non-interactive Arguments for
non-diseministic computations for
languages in NP
and and therefore a non-starter
assumptions or heuristic assumptions and
there is also a line of works on a
non-inter on non-interactive Arguments
for deterministic computations what uh
what's called snog's public and today
I'm going to uh to we will go in this
direction okay of the non-interactive
arguments for p
um okay so let me tell you what we know
about them
so um under polynomial assumptions we
can construct snacks okay
assuming uh
lwe OD
D so now again I'm going to ask the same
questions that I ask in the interactive
setting what about universality
if I look at these constructions can I
use them for Universal arguments
um so actually you get pretty much the
same thing
and so I can give an argument for all
computations but I need to know in
advance some upper bound people on T and
again in this case our my assumption is
has to be secure against adversaries of
size that depends on this Tiba
okay so oh yes sorry uh like probably
I'm curious like under polynomial
assumption you mean like a single
assumption that's secure against like a
whole point number time adversary like
forever
C yes exactly so I mean uh specifically
I mean uh LW or dealing
and I want the security of it to hold
against polynomial adversaries and this
is actually the standard assumption so
when we assuming this is what we assume
so it's not
it's not entity 100 science adversity
you know it's not a fixed polynomial
yeah it can be an important
but yeah but this construction doesn't
hit and doesn't give the Assumption it
doesn't give a it's not under its
assumption it means it needs an
assumption that might be stronger super
polynomial even some exponential okay
and so yeah I asked the same question in
the non-interactive setting and can we
give a snug for any computation
uh while we only assume uh an
assumptions that is a polynomial is
secure
so yeah this is the question that we try
to answer in this stuff and now let me
tell you about our results
so our main result is
a constructing non-interactive Universal
arguments and what we need to assume is
LW dealing which is a polynomial
assumption it's the same assumption that
we saw was used to construct a succinct
argument for non-universe argument
and we add an extra Assumption of a
foliomomorphic encryption
which I remind you depends on lwa and on
circular security
and we also need a mild worst case
complexity assumption and I will explain
it in more detail in the next slide
okay so this is our result and this is
how we answer the question that I just
asked and now I want to tell you a
little more about the results
so actually
we give a few different results where
there are mostly the same mainly they
are the same thing but we have some
different Notions of soundness in each
result
so
um in each results we also need the
different assumptions
so if we only need a non-interactive
universal argument with uniform
soundness so soundness only holds
against uniform adversaries all the
assumptions that we need are LW or
dealing the Assumption of the syntagonal
and fhe okay we don't need any complex
assumption
and now
um
if you want a non-interactive universal
argument with full soundness soundness
that falls also against non-uniform
adversaries
we need to add an extra complexity
assumption
which means
um so intuitively it means that
circuits of fixed polynomial size can
decide all P there will be some language
in in Peak that the circuits cannot
decide
and more formally for any constancy if
we look at all circuits of size entry
policy
there is some language in P that they
can decide Infantry
okay so this is our security our
complexity assumption and again we
consider it a mild
and another result we have is we extend
the previous result about Universal
arguments to the setting of
incrementally verifiable computation
and in this case and we need the same
assumptions only the complexity
assumption requires some has also a
space requirement okay so
um we can't speed up computations with
non-uniformity
even if they are bounded if their space
is bounded okay so this is
[Music]
um but again both these assumptions that
we consider mild and for example they
they follow from a non-uniform eth
so right
thank you uh sorry like if using LW is
like now uniform security it's like why
are those those two assumptions follow
up
is it because they're making polynomials
polynomial LW assumption instead of
exponential
sorry
uniform polynomial attackers and sorry
so no that won't be enough for us so
we'll see later in the construction
that's just assuming LW is not
yeah
something extra and this something extra
um we don't need it in the uniform case
okay we don't need to assume this if all
we need is some is against uniform
adversaries but if we want soundness
against non-uniform adversaries we will
have to assume we will see in the
construction where it comes in
yes yes
explain explain your way about some
um main theorem that we have behind all
of these results
so the way we show it the the results
that they now talked about is we take
snacks for P that I'll be mentioned
before the constructions that we have
with and we lift it into Universal
arguments which is what we want
and the way we leave them is we use a
cryptographic tool which is
cryptographic puzzles and I will explain
later what exact puzzles we need
okay so so this is what we're trying to
show and and actually
um
I wasn't very accurate so snacks for
Pete isn't enough for us we need
something a little stronger uh which in
this walk we call a semi-universal
arguments and what I mean by that it's
an argument that can prove any
computation but soundness is only
guaranteed if I have some fixed
polynomial upper bound on the
computation time t
so I take the semi-universal argument
and I leave them into an Universal
argument well soundness is guaranteed to
anything you know even T
in the size of two to the power of RAM
sorry in the bottom words
fixed ahead of time yes yes it needs to
be fixed before we Constructor
if it was just
would you be able to lift it or do you
need to be able to say you know
yeah
there is this a subsystem it is
um okay nice and so
um why is it okay to assume similar
versus arguments because actually as we
we saw before uh the existing
constructions that I mentioned for uh
snacks Poppy and they they actually are
a semi-universal argument
all right so we take what already exists
and we try to lift it into Universal
arguments and again we need to assume
that uh
soundness is we need some an argument
where soundness is guaranteed uh when T
is bounded by some polynomial and we
lift it into an argument when our
sadness is always guaranteed to anything
so um before we see the construction
let me explain a little bit uh why the
existing constructions aren't Universal
so suppose we have an adversary of
polynomial size and it tries to claim
some statements and NXT and we'll focus
on the case that we tries to make a
false statement
so what the existing constructions do is
the Constructor reduction that uses this
adversary to break their assumption LW
or billing foreign
okay so now it turns out that
um the reduction size obviously depends
on the size of the adversary but it
turns out that it also depends on T so
actually the reduction needs to make the
computation on its own
okay and this is where the problem comes
in so if if T is not bounded by any
polynomial this the reduction that we
got is not polynomial and then if we try
to break LW or dealing with it if it's
just a polynomial assumption it doesn't
do anything so that's that's the reason
we needed to assume something stronger
okay so yeah this is the problem and the
reduction size depends on
teeth and so let me explain how we solve
it
so
what we will actually want is that
the reduction size will only depend on
the adversary size and the way we do it
is we want to make sure the adversary
doesn't try to make
statements that it can't compute okay
and so if if the addressing only makes
uh statements that are approximately on
uh of the size of the adversary then we
have a polynomial upper bound on t
okay so um the way we do it is that we
ask the adversary uh when it tries to
prove some statements to also prove that
the that he made a t long computation
and if the adversary made a Tyrone
computation it means that t is actually
no bigger than the adversary and then
the size of the reduction is polynomial
yes
does it mean the size of the code that
generates immersive or the runtime of
the other person
the size of the non uniform adversary
yeah
okay
so how how can diversary pools see long
computation and that's where the puzzles
come in
so
um
so we asked the anniversary to solve a
puzzle that is the help
okay we'll see later exactly what is
this puzzle but intuitively it means
that if the adversaries of this puzzle
then it must have made a too long
complication
so that's the idea behind our behind our
construction and now let me Define the
cryptographic puzzles that we use
um okay so when we think about our
photographic puzzles we imagine that
there is some Challenger
and some solver the changer gets the
parameter t a difficulty parameter and
it sends to the server a puzzle instance
zip and the software needs to solve it
it sends back to the solution and then
the challenge the changel can verify now
there are different Notions of puzzles
in the literature for example time lock
puzzles and the proof of work and what
we are doing is we assume we we use the
simplest puzzle that is enough for our
requirements so let me tell you about
the properties we need from this puzzle
so first we need completeness which
means that there exists some solver that
will solve the puzzles in time
approximately
and we want fast sampling and
verification so the Challenger here that
samples the puzzle and then verifies it
is of size Only log T okay it doesn't
need to be able to solve the puzzle and
so on and now that the verification here
is public the changer doesn't need to
remember any state about the puzzle in
order to verify
and of course we want the title to be
held so we require soundness which means
that a solver that is significantly
smaller than T cannot solve the puzzer
okay so Epsilon here is some Gap so if I
have a solver that is smaller than t to
the Epsilon it won't be able to solve
the password
puzzles
and now
um let me let's see the construction and
how we use them
so as I said we start with a
semi-universal argument
so
the prover sends to the very first sum
proof and as I said in the same
Universal argument Samus only holds if T
is bounded by some polynomial
uh okay so how how do you make this
Universal that's where the puzzles come
in
so we add to the CRS Lambda puzzle
instances of increasing difficulty and
where the ice puzzle is of difficulty 2
to the power of I
and then we ask the proofer to solve the
puzzle log T which is a puzzle of
difficulty
and intuitively
if the proofer solves a positive
difficulty it had to run time T at least
and which is what we needed remember
from the idea we wanted to make sure
that the adversary doesn't make a
statement that it can't compute
um okay so now let me explain to you the
the idea around how we prove soundness
here
so
um assume we have some adversaries of
polynomial size and it tries to make a
statement a false statement NXT
now if the size of the adversary is
smaller than t to the Epsilon it's the
as its Epsilon it means that the
adversary shouldn't be able to solve
puzzle of difficulty p and then we can
use this adversary to break the
soundness of capacity
on the other hand if the adversary is
big and due to be excellent then now
that we have a polynomial upper bound on
T and this is a fixed point of a
polynomial upper bound it only depends
on the adversary size
so in this case we can just use the
soundness of the semi-universary
and so
yeah yeah
we we distinguish them we need to do it
when we poop but we don't need it while
the protocol runs
okay
so that's our construction and now
what's left for me is to explain how we
construct the cryptographic puzzles
so here the idea is that we start with
some problem that is a t hard in the
worst case okay and we have to assume
that something is hard to get a health
puzzle but not that this is a mild
assumption just to worst case hardness
and we list it into cryptographic
puzzles well in cryptographic Puzzles we
can sample puzzle instances from some
distribution and then
a small server that is a significantly
smaller
will want to be able to solve the
puzzles with high probability
um okay and the way we do it and we use
here is where we use volumetric
encryption
actually we also use here the
semi-universal arguments we'll see
okay so that's the basic idea and what
is our worst case T hard problem
so what we want is just some language
error that is decided by a turing
machine m in time t
and we want it to be worst case hard so
for any solver that is smaller than Q to
the Axon
it fails to decide some X
and but this it can be different for any
sort
so how do we get this problem
and that's where the difference come in
that they that we saw earlier so in the
uniform case we don't need to assume
anything and we can just use time
hierarchy theorems
in the non-uniform case that's where we
need a complexity assumption so we need
to assume that for any constancy if we
look at all circuits of size n to the
power of C
then there is some language that they
can decide infinitely of
and and this is our worst case heart
problem the exact language in P that
they can decide
okay
so now that we have a worst case health
problem let's see how we construct the
puzzles
so namely we can just uh the changer can
just send the the worst case Hub program
to the server and ask it to solve it
and the solver can make the computation
okay compute M on expertise steps
um okay but it doesn't really work this
way so we have one problem here which is
that actually as I said before it's it's
the worst case health problem so every
solver has a different instance that it
can't decide so how can the Challenger
know which instance to choose
and the solution for this
um so it was inspired by the work of
Chan kalai and vadan
there they show how to use polynomorphic
encryption to leverage worst case
hardness into average his happiness
so what we do
is actually we're going to do all of
this under
and then under the encryption okay so we
use the fully homomorphic encryption
scheme and everything here is going to
be under the encryption
and so the solver in order to solve the
puzzle what it needs to do is it needs
to homomorphically evaluate the
computation of M on X for T steps
um okay but now what what can what will
the Challenger sample what will in Will
It increase
so actually it doesn't matter what it
encrypts due to the security of the
encryption scheme the Challenger can
just encrypt the zero string in the
server can distinguish the case of the
encryption of the zero of resisting and
the encryption of the instance that is
helped for this specific solvent okay
and that's the way we get average case
happiness
foreign
okay why is it the problem is the
verified or distinguishes
or easy depends on the notes I don't
remember
what is inside the description
um okay what what we are trying is that
it will be difficult for the solver not
for the verifier so
knowing the cleans right the vehicles
so okay so the veteran doesn't disagree
no no they're very fast so no actually
the verified
okay
let's see how we worked how we verify
and then and see if there's still a
problem and so yeah there was a question
right you're trying to make it hard on
the average yes
yeah
and okay yeah so nobody mistakes
so the way we
um verified and that's where the same
Universal argument comes in so we just
asked the solver to send with its
solution and proof that he actually
evaluated the
homomorphically evaluate the computation
of M correctly
okay and so yeah so the janitor doesn't
need to make the computation of on its
own in order to verify it shouldn't
agree because it won't work I think
there is it won't be
sound if that's the way the challenge or
verify verified but we use the same
Universal argument and now the
Challenger can verify
okay so that's our puzzle and and I just
want to
um so that's our puzzle yes so here
we're really just using this on the
universal argument as a song for PA
right like would this could we just use
the character existing sorry for
pre-construction we're just using the
semi-universal argument as this
character be here right yes exactly as
oh no we know they need to be Universal
because it needs to prove a computation
that takes two steps and it's the same T
that we don't know any upper bound
and actually that's a great question
because
[Music]
um
there is one problem in this puzzle
which is if you use the same Universal
argument
so uh when you use a seven inverter
argument what we get is some sort of
stem Universal puzzle and what I mean by
that is that the soundness of the
feather only holds if T is some is upper
bounded by some polynomial like in the
semi reversal argument
um so let's see the construction again
and see whether it is a problem
um okay so we asked the approvert to
solve a puzzle of difficulty and what
we're trying to say is that if the
adversary tries to make a statement that
is bigger than it than itself that it
can compute then it won't be able to
solve the puzzle
but as I said in the universal language
we also have super polynomial t
so what if the adversary tries to make a
statement with the super polynomiality
then the soundness of the puzzle doesn't
hold
we don't know maybe the proofer the
diversary might be able to solve it it
might be able to convince the verifier
with its solution because the soundness
doesn't hold
so okay so use the same Universal
argument
and we got a semi Universal login it
seems like we didn't do anything and but
okay but it's okay there's a solution
for this uh so what we actually do in
our construction is uh we ask the
approver to solve all puzzles after
difficulty
and now there will be some puzzle here
in this row that is big enough but not
too big so big enough in a sense that a
polynomial adversary the the polynomial
adversary can't solve it okay if it
tries to make a statement that it cannot
compute there'll be some puzzle here
that it can solve and it's not too big
in the sense that it it's difficulties
people is still polynomial so since the
adversary is polynomial I can just take
the first puzzle that it can't compute
and its difficulty will still be
polynomial and now we can use our puzzle
okay great so this is our Construction
and now I just a quick note about future
directions so there is an important and
an interesting technique here of using
puzzles to reduce super polynomial
assumptions into polynomial assumptions
and so there is a question if it can be
if you can try this technique in
different settings so for example there
is also already a previous work of
bitanski and Solomon that uh that uses a
similar technique in the setting of a
leveraging uh leveled homomorphic
encryption into fully homologous
encryption so the use puzzle to reduce
the super polynomial assumptions in 2.0
assumptions there is a question if we
can do use this technique in other
places
okay that's it thank you
[Applause]
um
like separations
are there no separations
[Music]
we need this extra assumption
can you give just like a sentence of
intuition about how forcing the approver
to work with like the instance under fhc
make uh worst case like worst case
average case uh yes yes so
the idea is that
so yeah the idea is that the server is a
of size uh yeah okay so it can
distinguish an encryption of a zero
string from an encryption of the the
specific instance that we can solve okay
so you said that the solver that is too
small this sound instance that it cannot
solve and now we need to get the
encryption of zero if if you if it if it
is able to solve this encryption it
should also be able to solve the
encryption of the instantiate this
helpful
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign